bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce mercredi 10 février à lait
cru de l'hiver ont fait leur retour dans
les yvelines plusieurs communes touchées
port marly hardricourt poissy ou encore
meulan une situation rendue plus
difficile par la neige tombés la nuit
dernière le département restent sous
vigilance jaune
reportage auprès d'habitants de péniches
qui doivent composer avec ces épisodes
météorologiques
le maire de port marly est également
notre invité une entreprise insolite à
l'honneur également ce soir
depuis saint nom la bretèche la start-up
uv boosting met au point une machine
projetant de la lumière pour protéger
les plants de différentes maladies
et puis après l'arrêt du chantier dual
incendie de la cathédrale notre dame de
paris
les travaux de la collégiale de
mantes-la-jolie ont repris nous ferons
le point
juste avant cela le premier ministre
jean castex qui était en déplacement en
fin d'après midi aujourd'hui à
mantes-la-ville un déplacement dans le
cadre du projet de loi climat et
résilience présenté en conseil des
ministres ce mercredi 10 février
il était accompagné de la ministre de la
transition écologique barbara pompili
ainsi que de la ministre déléguée
chargée du logement emmanuelle wargon
ils se sont rendus sur le site de
l'ancienne friche industrielle de la
halle 6 heures pour le gouvernement la
reconquête des friches constitue un
enjeu majeur d'aménagement durable des
territoires également regarder ces
images la neige était au rendez-vous
dans les yvelines dans la nuit de mardi
à mercredi elle est tombée le
département était placé en vigilance
orange jusqu'à midi aujourd'hui
établissements et transports scolaires
étaient d'ailleurs tous deux à l'arrêt
ce mercredi côté circulation seule la
n118 est restée fermée de 21h hier soir
jusqu'à la fin de matinée ce mercredi
quelques perturbations également eu lieu
dans les transports en commun notamment
des ralentissements sur la ligne c du
rer car la neige bloquait les appareils
de voie les yvelines reste tout de même
en
silence jaune pour neige verglas et
grand froid ainsi que pour cru et
justement les crues de l'hiver c'est le
sujet dont nous allons parler maintenant
depuis près d'une semaine les crues ont
fait leur grand retour dans les yvelines
comme je vous le disais le département
est d'ailleurs toujours en vie lisant
vigilance pardon jaune à ce sujet la
scène est donc particulièrement sous
surveillance les péniches qui
stationnent sur le bras de marly doivent
faire face à ce phénomène qui revient
quasiment chaque année
reportage de bixente mais rien senti
steban et patrick jacques de dixmude la
scène sous surveillance
les péniches se sont déjà organisés pour
faire face à d'éventuels débordements
c'est le cas de clément chantôme est
vigilant n'est pas inquiet pour le monde
imagine crû de moyenne ampleur j'ai
envie de dire on a vécu bien pire en
janvier 2018 hulu était à peu près à
médecin au dessus par rapport à ce qu'on
vit aujourd'hui savoir que la scène est
un fleuve de plaine donc c'est les as
rempli comme une grosse baignoire c'est
pas du tout comme on peut voir
actuellement
dans le sud ouest de la france où c'est
plutôt des fleuves où des torrents de
montagne qui déverse énormément dans
bach
parmi les principaux enjeux en temps de
crue l'amarrage contrairement à la
situation dans paris sur le bras de
marly les péniches peuvent être
maintenus à distance des quais peu
importe la crue on a la chance d'avoir
des systèmes d'amarrage qui sont assez
performants de pouvoir remonter soit sûr
et coire soit sur du galbe dons qui sont
des gros poteaux qui permet de retenir
le bateau ils empêchaient de dg vers le
quai donc ça c'est une très bonne
solution pour maintenir le bateau en
place bien anticipé c'est l'une des
raisons d'exister de la bpm association
des bateaux du bras de paul mara lee
elle permet par exemple aux habitants du
fleuve d'entretenir un lien avec la
commune
l'idée en fait c'est de communiquer très
rapidement entre la mairie et le et le
bureau de la bm des informations sur des
éléments de sécurité et une vigilance
une vigilance et une intervention plus
rapide et anticiper les bateliers plus
aguerris peuvent aussi conseiller et
aider les moins expérimentés en cas de
problème on a créé des groupes de
référents qui sont des binômes qui vont
surveiller et qui vont collecter
l'information et des centres
d'information sur six bateaux et qui
permet une communication très rapide
entre les référents et le bureau de la
bm c'est une quarantaine de bateaux
stationnés dans les environs qui
partagent leur expérience du fleuve
via cette association ils font face
ensemble à cette situation à risque pour
continuer à parler de ce sujet nous
accueillons cédric pemba marine bonsoir
vous êtes le maire de port marly alors
hors marly c'est une commune où passe un
fleuve en l'occurrence la scène d'abord
cédric pemba marine comment avez vous
vécu ses premières recrues de l'hiver en
tant que maire alors je ne sais pas si
vous m'entendez cédric pemba marine
alors la connexion est très mauvaise
nous allons essayer de vous reprendre un
peu plus tard
est-ce que vous m'entendez nous allons
vous reprendre un peu plus tard cédric
pemba marine si jamais vous m'entendez
à poissy ce mardi une journée
d'information sur les enjeux de la
citoyenneté et de la défense était
organisée au collège jean jaurès dans
une classe de 3e les élèves ont pu
découvrir cette thématique à travers un
jeu de société
un reportage de michael et demi d'euros
apprendre en s'amusant ce mardi 9
février 31 élèves du collège jean jaurès
de poissy ont pu tester un jeu de
société sur le thème de la défense
l'événement était organisé dans le cadre
d'une journée d'information sur les
enjeux de la citoyenneté
la partie dure en moyenne deux heures il
est très ludique en fait les élèves
jouent en collaboration pour contrer les
menaces est vraiment un jeu où ils sont
tous en équipe et ils vont avoir
différents rôles par exemple il va avoir
le rôle du président ou le rôle des
interventions qui va décider où les
françaises doivent intervenir
donc ça leur montre vraiment les moyens
que la france dispose pour contrer les
menaces et les menaces existantes dans
le monde entier une heure de
concentration et des changes premières
réactions de ses élèves de 3e sur ce
tout nouveau juge ça change des cours
classiques ans et interactif et bah ça
nous change de d'habitude je le trouve
bien stratégique faut réfléchir pour
parler avec ses camarades pour choisir
les choix à faire ce rendez vous était
une grande première pour le collège jean
jaurès de poids si ça répond à des
questions et ça vient en complément
voilà de ce qu'on fait en classe
notamment en éducation morale et civique
ou en cours sur la défense nationale
sur toutes les
la dimension citoyenne les valeurs de la
république
la journée s'est prolongée par d'autres
jeux sur les métiers de la défense et de
la mémoire chaque semaine des
interventions sur le lien armée nation
sont organisées dans les collèges
yvelinois direction saint nom la
bretèche maintenant installée sur le
site des fermes they are la start-up uv
boosting conçoit des machines qui
diffusent de la lumière pour protéger
les plantes des champignons un procédé
inédit une découverte en images montées
par lucas ou d'art de la lumière pour
protéger les plantes des champignons
c'est le pari de la start-up uv boosting
créé en 2010 est par deux chercheurs
d'avignon est aujourd'hui installée à
saint nom la bretèche
elle a inventé une machine composée de
panneaux lumineux qui se fixe sur un
tracteur le principe est assez simple on
vient exposer les plantes en
l'occurrence par exemple des lignes à
une un flash du vc donc une dose
lumineuse très courte mais très intense
ce qui va enclencher chez la plante un
processus d'activation de ses défenses
naturelles ce qui va la rendre plus
résistantes à différents agresseurs
notamment dans le cas de la vigne le
mildiou et l'oïdium
en 2020 la société a commercialisé une
quinzaine de machines en champagne un
bourgogne ou encore dans le bordelais un
investissement pour les clients entre 36
milles et 54 mille euros qui permettrait
de réduire de moitié l'utilisation des
pesticides uv boosting a développé cette
technologie pour permettre justement aux
agriculteurs aux viticulteurs de réduire
leur dépendance aux produits fongicides
conventionnelle c'est parti d'un constat
assez relativement partagés que
aujourd'hui les consommateurs et les
producteurs ont pour la plupart envie
d'une agriculture plus durable et plus
saine pour l'environnement
depuis sa création la start up a
embauché une quinzaine de salariés et
prévoit de recruter des commerciaux mais
aussi des ingénieurs comme loïc employé
depuis 2010 est mon travail c'est de
faire en sorte que cette solution soit
la plus efficace possible à la fois en
coalisant production mais également pas
pour travailler avec tous les
partenaires de recherche qui nous
aideront ensuite eux aussi de leur côté
à optimiser et à rendre plus efficace
plus efficiente moins coûteuse
enfin juste améliorer la solution après
une première vente en afrique du sud
uv boosting souhaiterait à l'avenir se
développer à l'international tout en
continuant bien sûr à commercialiser ses
machines en france pour protéger les
futurs millésime
alors nous avons réussi à retrouver
cédric pemba marie maire de port marly
on va donc parler avec vous des crues de
l'hiver comme je le disais tout à
l'heure
première question série clem marine
comment avez vous vécu ses premières
recrues de l'hiver en tant que maire or
ces premières colvert on est venu on ne
vit toujours avec une saprée
d'appréhension même sinon on commence à
être habitué ses deux pilotes qui ne
trompera étrangers dernier datant de
il a fallu aller d'aborder le plus
sereinement possible avec une vigilance
accrue avant que la tête et bord de son
os on dit et on s'organise événement
avec les ferries politiquement et
justement alors quelle organisation
faut-il mettre en place quand on est une
municipalité
quel protocole à suivre alors le propre
cas là dessus c'est une surveillante de
très près du niveau de la traîne
on a des échelles de crue situé le long
de la seine à proximité de la mairie
un policier municipal qui est chargé
d'aller payer la montée de la seine
parallèlement à ça on a aussi les
alertes
suivez paris rue et par la préfecture à
partir de là quand on approche des
niveaux critiques
il ya une information autre part par
différents canaux aux riverains de la
scène pour qu'ils puissent s'organiser
notamment d'opérer des partis n'en
sous-sol et pour les habitants du fleuve
se préparer en installant des bastaings
leur permettant de rejoindre la rive
malgré la montée de l'eau et du coup y
at-il eu des dégâts dans votre commune
ces derniers jours avec avec les cruches
donc les niveaux au niveau des
constructions les normes sont telles que
c'est limite considérablement les dégâts
les dégâts les plus importants qu'on
peut constater qu'on constate cru après
cru c'est te lever à l'environnement
espère que toutes les matières
plastiques qui navigue dans le fleuve
qui sont accumulés au barrage et quand
les balles apparaissent sont ouverts
pour à réguler un peu le niveau d'eau
c'est c'est autant de matières qu'on
retrouve nous sur les rives
après après la crue est justement on va
écouter un habitant alors pas de votre
commune du port marly mais bien de
poissy et plus précisément de lille
mignot lui ici est confronté à ces
problématiques de crue de la seine
on l'écoutait au micro de célia garçons
gauche admettons qu'ils si l'eau monte
encore de 40 cm ça va mouiller mais mais
ça va inonder des taux de garage mais
ils sont vidés j'ai pris deux garçons
avec des solides et plus jeune que moi
et puis on a toujours on a monté tout ce
qu'ils avaient inventé les les autos on
les a sortis on les a mis dans un garage
et puis voilà
si ça peut durer dix jours deux jours
et puis la scène se retire
l'eau se retire avec ce qu'il faut faire
c'est passé le kärcher tout de suite
derrière parce que l'eau de la seine est
incroyablement plein de limoux vous m'en
parliez juste avant on l'a entendu cet
habitant conseil de nettoyer très
rapidement après que l'eau soit
redescendue lors d'une crue car la scène
véhicules des déchets c'est ce que vous
m'avez dit est ce que c'est un problème
récurrent vraiment récurrent dans votre
commune et qu elle est un petit peu la
solution face à cela un problème
récurrent et un problème qu'on redoute à
chaque fois et sur lequel pour un format
on a avancé mais insuffisamment pour
mémoire en 2008
peu à peu près de 30 tonnes de déchets
qui permet leur course aux barrages de
méricourt un peu plus on en devine nous
ce qu'on veut parvenir à faire et c'est
pour ça qu'on a lancé tout dernièrement
un appel aux différentes collectivités
concernées à l'état et aux entreprises
privées qui pourraient nous apporter
leur aide
on en a une sur deux cas l'histoire de
la commune qui possède le matériel
adéquat et de ce serait compliqué à
organiser pour ramasser ces déchets en
amont notamment au moment où ils
arrivent sur les barrages à proximité
alors nous avons parlé des crues des
inondations mais la neige et le verglas
se sont également invités dans la nuit
de mardi à mercredi
comment ça s'est passé au port marly
dans votre commune avec la neige s'est
endettée avec la crue il a fallu que les
à terme il était déjà mort depuis qu'ils
ont été les habitants sur la partie
crurent en procédant à quelques
aménagements sur les berges de seine là
il aura fallu dès hier soir protéger un
présalage de préventif et puis ça m'a
tant qu à 5 heures du matin retournez
l'intégralité des voix municipal un peu
plus tard aussi normal mais là on veille
en veille permanente et j'imagine que
vous resterez en tout cas en alerte
jusqu'à la fin de l'hiver vigilance
jaune toujours dans les yvelines
je le rappelle pour neige verglas grand
froid ainsi que cru merci sedrine pemba
marine d'avoir été avec nous faire
en france 11 millions de personnes sont
considérées comme aidants familiaux
face à la maladie ou à la dépendance de
leur proche elles se sentent parfois
seul et dépassés sur le plan physique
émotionnel social et financier pour les
épauler l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines propose un programme
d'accompagnement dédié avec une
nouveauté
explications de grégory canale et
patrick jacques de dixmude
ce matin là pierre assiste à un entrée
dans café pas d'atelier en présentiel
pour se plier au contexte sanitaire la
rencontre se déroule en visioconférence
suivi directement depuis son domicile à
montigny le bretonneux un ton chaleureux
pour échanger s'informer et créer du
lien autour d'une thématique exemple
pour cette discussion la préservation
des relations de couple c'est une
occasion de débattre de sujets qui
finalement nous concerne on puisque des
mâles on s'est plutôt sympathique et on
rencontre des gens qui ont les mêmes
problèmes que nous et qui les ont résolu
de façon parfois différentes et il ya
peut-être des choses à reprendre
en 2009 les médecins diagnostiquent à
son épouse une maladie génétique
son état se dégrade rapidement et pierre
se retrouve alors désemparé pour
s'occuper d'elle
il a besoin d' aide via la mutuelle de
son épouse liniment teint est mise en
relation avec l'institut de promotion de
la santé de saint quentin en iv
l'accompagnement des personnes
handicapées malades etc
ça comporte de très nombreux aspects que
ce soit financier juridique aide au
ménage aide à la toilette etc
il n'y a pas un guichet unique cassé
c'est au hasard des rencontres pour
prévenir l'épuisement et épauler les
aidants l'institut de promotion de la
santé propose un programme
d'accompagnement dédié
en plus des entrées dans café des
groupes de paroles et de soutien sont
déployés tout comme des ateliers
thématiques avec pour objectif de se
détendre et de mettre en pratique des
conseils
enfin une nouveauté le passe temps libre
la possibilité de se faire relayer
gratuitement auprès de son procédé pour
un temps de répit en finançant des
heures d'auxiliaire de vie qui peut qui
peuvent remplacer les dents aux côtés de
la personne aidée
c'est un dispositif qui se met en route
depuis très peu de temps qui s'appuie
sur les compétences des services d'aidé
à domicile qui interviennent sur le
territoire au premier trimestre 2010
environ 200 et dans était accompagné par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines pour refermer ce journal le
travail de restauration de la collégiale
notre dame de mantes la jolie vient de
reprendre après des travaux d'urgence
achevé en 2017 c'est toute une partie de
l'édifice vieux de 800 ans qui va subir
des transformations
un travail minutieux réalisé par des
entreprises spécialisées sous la
houlette de la mairie un reportage de
justin brasier et astrid bergère la
restauration de la collégiale de
mantes-la-jolie a repris après une phase
de travaux d'urgence achevé en 2017 un
grand plan de rénovation va avoir lieu
jusqu'en 2023
un programme de restauration qui a été
établie par des spécialistes
il se déroulera en deux phases la phase
une c'est les terrasses les tribunes et
la mise hors d'eau d'un certain nombre
de choses c'est à dire éviter que
l'édifice ne se dégrade plus en faisant
des travaux et ensuite un travail aussi
sur les coursives sur les élévations
contre les élévations de tribunes et sur
les maçonneries l'édifice est en
propriété de la mairie c'est elle qui
organise les rénovations difficile de
trouver des spécialistes pour les
travaux et encore plus après l' incendie
de notre dame de paris et surtout le
coût est important remet sur à peu près
sur les faces une et deux à trois
millions cinq cent mille euros de
travaux toutes taxes comprises donc
c'est quand même d'aider des montants
importants
mais heureusement on est accompagné on
est accompagné par la région par le
département par l'état via la direction
régionale des affaires culturelles et
aussi par du mécénat privé mais pour la
mairie comme pour le curé ces travaux
sont plus que nécessaires
cette collégiale qui date de plus de 800
ans et la fierté de mantes-la-jolie un
immense bâtiment comme celui-là
multiséculaire depuis 13ème 14ème siècle
il faut absolument qu'ils aient des
rénovations quasi permanente
c'est une des plus grandes églises des
yvelines surtout aussi ancien c'est la
plus grande et on pourrait dire de tout
l'ouest parisien
c'est la grand la grande église gothique
de l'ouest parisien
mais pour les fidèles et les touristes
pas d'inquiétude les travaux n'auront
pas d'impact sur les célébrations et sur
l'ouverture de la collégiale c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
l'information revient demain à 18h en
direct dans le 7-8 journal présenté par
grégory canale et d'ici là je souhaite
une excellente soirée
[Musique]